hi I'm Erik Bosse and soullow a Star
Wars story has a new trailer that
actually gives me hope for this movie
Alden Ehrenreich sakteng small didn't
spare in Reich's SHM acting he seems
fine and I'll take a Star Wars train
heist with chewy woody Donald Glover and
HBO actors any day so I'm gonna break
down this trailer frame by frame
pointing out all the new details that
you might have missed and spoiler
warning in case any of these predictions
are too perfect cool let's hit start
[Applause]
[Music]
you're after something
[Music]
is it revenge okay the trailer opens on
Han Solo's homeworld of Corellia you can
see it's grimy industrial looking city
and this upward looking shot of an
imperial star destroyer undergoing
repairs it reminds me a lot of the Jedi
shots and rogue one I like the detail
the little rat creature running along
the cable it could be a normal rat if
not for that weird tail this reminds me
of the recurring shots and movie the
departed with the rat running along the
banister the rat was used as a symbol of
the corruption deceit of those
characters in that whole world this
image revokes a similar feel for this
movie it'll be a story about the less
noble criminal side of this whole Star
Wars universe then we see Han Solo
standing off in a cowboy styled duel
against this villain character this was
confirmed to be in feasts nest described
as an extremely dangerous Marauder who
quickly forged an infamous reputation
for herself the crew is a gang of
pirates called the cloud riders in my
breakdown of the first trailer which you
should definitely go watch I pointed out
how her mask and helmet has the design
of Mandalorian armor that's a style of
armor worn by characters like Boba Fett
also the legends character Darth Revan
and on that helmet are some or vege
letters at the time I could make out you
oh and an R and here you can see that
our top to helmet spikes are actually
serrated blades that she inserted making
close combat with her even more deadly
and of course Hans unclipping to his
blaster holster is a nice little nod to
his background as a scoundrel who shoots
first Norway this trailer really wants
us to identify Aaron right gets the
classic Han Solo let's move on
money or is it something else
you look good little rough around the
edges but good
heard about a job okay in this section
Han walks in on Lando Calrissian played
by Donald Glover raking in the chips
from what looks like a game of sabacc
and I just love this freak show of
practical puppets and costume aliens
joining him at the table very much
evokes the classic Mos Eisley cantina as
and what JJ Abrams was going for in maz
kanata's Club in the force awakens
restaurant chain Denny's actually did a
han Solo commercial for trading cards
that actually gives the names for some
of these months trustees thanks Benny's
his old lobster claw hands
his name is therms scissor punch
meanwhile in the bottom corner that's
Argus six eyes panics can't imagine how
I got that name then a close-up shows
that Han is going all in on one hand
suggesting this could be the specific
game of sabacc that legend has it Han
won the Millennium Falcon from Lando
then we see Han examining the Falcon in
the next shot with Chewbacca in a
previous trailer was just Han looking at
Falcon suggesting that Juhi was added in
post-production or in reshoots
same goes for this shot of Han and Kyra
descending the dune honestly if Ron
Howard's biggest contribution to the
resuits of this movie was just these
dudes need a bit more chewy
I am totally okay with that let's move
on big shot gangster putting together
crew I'm a driver and I'm a flier
the waited a long time for a shot like
this
what do you say
well what do you know here Woody
Harrelson's character Tobias Beckett
briefs Han on a job backed by a new
character were seeing for the first time
Paul Bettany's character a gangster
named Dryden vas now no relation to You
Tube gangster Erik Bosse wait a minute
papa I should also say no relation to
Quinlan vos the Jedi from legends in the
animated series Dryden vos was
originally going to be played by Michael
K Williams who was unfortunately
unavailable for reshoot so they had to
recast him with Bettany Emilia Clarke's
character Keira is apparently an
associate of Dryden Keira grew up with
Hana Corellia explaining why she appears
in the scenes of the two of them in that
speeder chase now it appears that their
paths have changed with Keira moving up
in the criminal underworld we also see
Han talking that Imperial recruitment
officer that he met with in the first
trailer pitching himself as a driver and
a flyer ironically intercut with clips
of him driving and flying away from
Imperial Stormtroopers and then we see
this shot of the big set piece from this
movie on this snowy mountain planet this
place is called van door and Hans job
looks to be a kind of train heist
stealing a box car from this transport
which is called the conveyux if you look
closely Hans ship appears to be in a
sort of tug of war over this boxcar with
these other crafts that actually matched
the vessels that we saw earlier with the
cloud riders so it appears that these
rival gangs of thieves are both going
after the same loped we also see Val
Tannen Newton's character who's a
longtime partner of Beckett Beckett
kisses a blaster and tosses it behind
this is actually Hans dl-44 blaster that
we've seen him used throughout the Star
Wars series perhaps we'll get an origin
story for the weapon here and then this
exchange between Han and Chewie
well what do you know all the voters
we've seen this moment felt the most
true to the spirit of Han Solo in his
relationship with Chewbacca and based on
his surroundings it looks like Chewie is
advising him against making a big move
in that game of sabacc we'll clean it up
let's move on yeah smuggler around I
heard his story about you I was
wondering if it's true everything you
tried about me it's true okay in this
section Han and Chewie scale up to this
impressive mountainside structure with
these massive tusks marking the entrance
I'm guessing this is actually the
location han first encounters Lando
which I would love because it kind of
evokes Indiana Jones in Raiders of the
Lost Ark Jones teamed up with his
partner Marion Ravenwood in a similar
Mountain tavern running into her right
after a badass drinking game similar to
the gamble Han finds Lando in the middle
of here as they sit across from each
other Lando says everything you heard
about me is true this is a cool parallel
to Han Solo's line in the force awakens
when Rey blathers on about the myths
she's heard about these legendary
figures it's true all this droid
cocktail server tops off lambdas drink
in that Denny's ad the beverage appears
to be the classic blue bantha milk but I
would imagine Lando would want some a
bit stronger also if you look closely at
the pile of chips on the table there's a
faint little glimmer there I'm wondering
if that could belong to Hans lucky
golden dice which of course showed up in
the earlier shot hanging from the rear
view on that speeder and yeah it played
such a huge role in the last Jedi anyway
I assume we'll see him toss out those
dice at some point in this game moving
on let's go with the mean man's face
these guys
[Music]
if you come with us you're in this life
for good might wanna buckle up baby in
this clip we see Lando's droid l 337
voiced by actress Phoebe Waller bridge I
mentioned before that the name L 337 is
a reference to leat the nerdy Internet
language we also see a wide shot of the
Millennium Falcon here and yeah you
might notice how its nose looks a lot
different normally there are two prongs
with a gap in between them my guess is
that this extra section is part of the
ships cargo holds that will be removed
later on and as we get more shots of the
Falcons pristine not yet grind up
interior we see Han joining Lando and l3
in the cockpit where Lando says you
might want to buckle up baby I like how
l3 smacks her own head maybe you're
trying to work out a canker maybe just
mocking Don I'm being such a skeptical
idiot the ship's speed capabilities
let's move on to the next section soon
everyone will betray you
you'll never be disappointed okay here
on the Vander conveyux we see a new
variant of the stormtrooper called range
troopers and check out their boots that
light up those are magnetic they allow
the range trooper to walk on the surface
of the conveyux even when it rolls over
on its side you can see the cable at
Beckett's feet there he's clearly trying
to attach it to this boxcar so it can be
lifted out meanwhile in a wider shot of
this shootout you can see Han ship
hovering over the Train next we see the
Falcon soaring toward a planet now in
addition to Corellia there are a few
other new planets that are supposed to
appear in this movie one of them is
Kessel the origin point of the famous
Kessel run Kessel is home to various
spice mines from which smugglers like
han and Lando and Beckett delivered to
wealthier planets like croissant but we
see a closer look of the other new
planet here in this shot of an 80s tea
chicken Walker it lands in this swampy
region this is a planet tomb in bon min
bon is another planet from old Star Wars
lore from legends novels like splinter
of the mind's eye it was going to be
featured in other various Star Wars
movies it was originally referred to as
bog planet in bond comes with its own
storm trooper variant the mud trooper
which you can see here there's a man
weakly also released a promo still of
NIMH bond that gives us a better look
it's also a quick shot of valve firing
neck cable hook at the conveyux and then
this interesting shot of chilly and
breezy and another Wookiee some are
saying this could be his wife mala or a
son lumpy who appeared in the amazing
Star Wars Holiday Special
in Chuy's previous backstory from
legends which might be revised for this
movie han actually found him among a
group of Wookiee slaves that were being
forced into labor by the Empire han
wasn't training as an imperial officer
and he had a change of heart
deciding to save Chuy's life creating
the lifelong bond between the two of
them perhaps this scene is from Chuy's
escape when he's saying goodbye to
another Wookiee companion as they part
ways on leading captivity let's move on
I got a really good feeling about this
[Music]
190 years old
great here we see more shots the Falcon
rolling through space evading the
tentacles of this giant space monster
han says he's got a real good feeling
about this
obviously nodding that is well-known
pessimism that I'll have as an older
more seasoned smuggler my last trailer
break down I speculated that this whole
sequence could be taking place in that
infamous Kessel run which is an asteroid
field containing within a nebula it
definitely looks like those Tie Fighters
are chasing the Falcon through asteroids
there we also get a confirmation of
Chewbacca's age 190 years old actually
lines up with the Chewie timeline we've
had before he's supposed to be over 230
years old around the time of the force
awakens in the last Jedi and 200 in the
first Star Wars rookies tend to live
around 400 years so yeah maybe let's
show this elderly walking carpet some
respect huh all right let's move on to
this last section
[Music]
[Music]
okay in this final clip Dryden Voss
shows off a nasty-looking weapon some
kind of cross between brass knuckles and
a red laser bleed they look kind of like
a similar design as the melee weapons
used by the Praetorian guards in the
last Jedi and if you look closely he's
slashing those at Han here maybe this is
how Han will get that scar on his chin
like so Louis Star Wars story could do a
similar move that Indiana Jones and Last
Crusade did with River Phoenix whippin
themself on the chin to explain the
origin of Harrison Ford's chin scar then
some more battle shots on min bond with
mud troopers and then a shot of chewy
completely wrecking the trooper that
guy's head went back in his body surely
like Reverse Rock'em Sock'em doom and
then after Kira throws a grenade we
close out on this shot of Han and chewy
on the convey X with Chewie losing his
footing as it rolls Boulder coming in an
Entertainment Weekly photo of this
moment show that the two of them are
clinging to part of the train with these
Arabic signs those letters translate to
hitch joint and hitch please solo
trailer you're not fooling anyone by
making us think Chuy's gonna die here
the Wookiees only in like five future
Star Wars films like either he'll get
pulled to safety or even cooler his body
goal just like obliterate this Boulder
but you know what solo a Star Wars story
isn't looking like a guessing game over
who's gonna live who's gonna die the way
rogue one was this movie's aiming to be
a thrilling caper that shows how our
favorite heroes became the man and space
bear that we know them to be but a
question for you guys what do you think
is the loot that Han and the others are
trying to steal from this conveyux
something valuable like Kyber crystals
or a human bounty like rebel prisoners
with some VIPs in there I'm just curious
to see if this prize has merely monetary
value or if it could end up being
something that connects solo to the
broader Star Wars narrative in some way
comment down below with your theories or
tweet me directly idea of a sand follow
new rock stars on Twitter for updates on
our videos like this video share it
around and subscribe to new rock stars
for everything Star Wars related and
yeah be sure to check out my breakdown
of the first solo trailer thanks for
watching guys bye